c'est quand même positif de mettre à
l'épreuve le concept de travail à
distance
je pense que j'ai beaucoup du rac sont
en train d'évaluer ce que ça fonctionne
nous ça fonctionne pas dans les
situations comme ça on n'a pas le choix
que ça fonctionne je pense pas qu'on va
vouloir me théry à un monde 5,05 du
télétravail pour 135g au paradis mais je
pense qu'on va avoir plus de flexibilité
sur les plantations de télétravail soit
de façon occasionnelle quand il ya des
événements comme ses partenaires sont
compliquées sur les réseaux soient mal
implanté régulièrement dans l'eau
semaine ou deux journées de l'e-commerce
par semaine ça va s'organiser mieux
maintenant qu'elle a mise à l'épreuve
avoir été fait donc si on arrive à
réduire sa tante et de gens qui veulent
se déplacer en même temps que ce soit
dans le réseau transports en commun ou
non de moutier on voit mieux les
utiliser et si on fait une bonne gestion
assuré que les conditions de déplacement
s'améliore on enlève des déplacements
nos réseaux notamment des réseaux route
ils le savent a dit que les plans de
déplacements aux huit meilleurs ça va
aller plus vite en haut tout le temps
moi je vais choisir mon mode étrangères
écoutons semprun 75 ne tente pas quand
même là c'est rendu que ça prend 60
minutes en auto tonge on peut avoir cet
effet rebond par la réduction de la
demande sur les réseaux outils on peut
exister des gens qui ne sont pas dans
leur dignité avec ma phrase automobile
pour se déplacer il se trouve à la
tension pourquoi générique demande cette
semaine quand on essaie de s'améliorer y
consentent circulation pour tout le
monde
comment on fait pour assurer que mobiles
deviennent plus compétitifs parce qu'on
essaie d'améliorer conditions de
circulation est souvent sépare de la
tarification des politiques que les gens
n'aiment pas mettre en place des
restrictions stationnement
d'applications passionnément la
tarification plus mythique des péages
l'augmentation des prix de l'essence
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à maintenir
un équilibre assuré qu'il est en
déplacement à rouen est bon si on enlève
quotidiennement 20 % des travailleurs
sur le réseau
peu importe le mode qu'ils choisissent
de prendre activement pour se déplacer
ça va permettre de réduire de 10 % des
gaz à effet de serre sur une base
annuelle
quand on choisit d'investir dans quelque
chose facile voir quels sont les autres
impacts collectivement de plonger sur 10
équipés en tous les cas le médecin on
veut améliorer la qualité bio améliorer
le bilan santé bible et on verrait d'un
accident et améliorer le niveau des prix
et options sur lesquelles on veut
travailler la question du télétravail ça
peut aller j'ai le stress de certains
travailleurs car on sait qu elle déjà
compris ma position pro macbook 13
pouces intérêt plus fort si on réduit le
débit de circulation elles ont réduit le
principal facteur de reald accident
c'est positif
c'est une super idée je pense que ça va
quand même invité les gens à marcher
plus est ce c'est génial pour la marche
d'un mode de transport
on est souvent négligé la marche à
travers de pain la marche à nous permet
vraiment d'aller loin parce que les
avocats prennent réaliser sa selle
n'auront pas qu on dit aussi que la
marche et vélo celi mode de transport
qui peuvent être utilisés pour des
déplacements utilitaires pas juste pour
aller prendre une marche comme on le
fait aujourd'hui pour aller à des
destinations
on est en train de voir peut-être
organiser limoux ville pour que ce soit
plus attractif de se déplacer avec des
modes actifs le gros potentiel concentré